una fecha el 23 de junio de 2016 ese día
se produjo un acontecimiento que hizo
temblar los cimientos de toda europa por
primera vez un país miembro de la unión
europea decidía romper y largarse del
club
[Música]
desde entonces fuera del reino unido-
hay un gran consenso sobre qué es lo que
va a ocurrir no dejamos de escuchar que
las consecuencias del break city serán
terribles para este país crisis
desempleo la cidh ya está acabada
londres no volverá a pintar nada en el
mundo etcétera etcétera etcétera la
caída de la libra y la inestabilidad que
se puede generar puede provocar un
empobrecimiento de las personas que
viven en gran bretaña respecto al resto
del mundo y luego también están las
amenazas de la unión europea una
organización por cuya reacción más que
una institución política aparece un
novio celoso al que acaban de dejar que
avisa a los británicos que la factura
del presi será muy cara vale reino unido
ha decidido largarse pero al fin y al
cabo son libres de hacerlo no os parece
si yo también entiendo reacciones como
las de la unión europea pero no las
comparto para nada para que tantas
amenazas no será mejor tratar de
negociar y alcanzar un acuerdo que
beneficia a las dos partes sí sí sé que
algunos dicen que o se le da un
escarmiento al reino unido o puede que
otros países decidan seguir sus pasos
pero entonces la intención es dar
para que nadie más se atreva a
cuestionar a la unión europea plantear
sobre una cosa tan seria un referéndum
cuando la gente sobre la verdadera
y operatividad y la realidad
europea personalmente eso me parece un
poco de matones desde luego yo apuesto
más por prestar atención a los motivos
que puede conducir a un país a querer
irse que por la política del miedo pero
no nos desviemos bien con todo esto una
pregunta que nos podemos hacer es esta
se va a quedar acaso reino unido- solo
aislado tras el break
pues cuidado con afirmar que sí porque
hay en marcha movimientos que pueden
cambiar el mundo tal y como lo conocemos
y desde luego el futuro tras el brasil
no está ni mucho menos decidido
a las puertas del nuevo imperio
británico
a decir verdad ser parte de la unión
europea nunca ha motivado mucho a los
británicos de hecho se unieron en 1973 y
tan solo dos años más tarde ya
celebraron un primer referéndum para ver
si se quedaban o se marchaban
y ganó el sí pero desde entonces en
downing street digamos que han tenido
entre sus prioridades políticas limitar
el proyecto europeo una construcción
económica pero no política e incluso así
con matices de hecho reino unido ha sido
siempre un rara avis dentro del club
comunitario por ejemplo se han quedado
fuera de proyectos tan importantes y tan
emblemáticos como el euro o el espacio
señor
[Música]
así que llegados a este punto podemos
preguntarnos que se les pasa por la
cabeza a los británicos para tener tanta
animadversión a la unión europea vale es
verdad los motivos son muchos pero uno
de los más importantes no os lo dejo ya
claro ni más ni menos que winston
churchill atentos en 1946 cuando
pronunció su famoso discurso de furyk en
el que dijo dos cosas
primero que apostaba por la construcción
de unos estados unidos de europa pero
eso sí entre los países de la europa
continental
vamos que apoyaba la aventura pero que
ellos no cogían el tren y lo segundo que
dijo es que ellos ya tenían su propio
club la mancomunidad de naciones de la
commonwealth que en esa época ya se
estaba montando para dar acogida a todos
los países que se iban independizando
del imperio es decir que los británicos
soñaban con tener su propio club y ese
sentimiento para muchos hoy no ha
cambiado sobre todo respecto a algunas
antiguas colonias construidas a imagen y
semejanza de la metrópoli
[Música]
y me explico dentro del imperio
británico podríamos encontrar
fundamentalmente dos tipos de colonias
las colonias de explotación las más
habituales que consistían en ocupar un
territorio para aprovecharse de sus
recursos naturales en este tipo de
colonias el asentamiento de población
blanca era reducido y el desarrollo
institucional más bien escaso
[Aplausos]
por así decirlo el imperio británico
pactada con los gerifaltes locales y les
mantenían el poder a cambio de su
cooperación por otro lado estaban los
dominios que recibían mucha población
blanca y reproducían el modelo de país
que había en casa en la metrópoli este
es el tipo de colonización que dio lugar
a los países más ricos como canadá
australia o nueva zelanda también a eeuu
pero éste consiguió independizarse muy
pronto el caso es que es con estos
últimos países con los que los
británicos identifican más al fin y al
cabo son política social y culturalmente
muy similares y ojo ese sentimiento de
afinidad e incluso de hermandad es
compartido también por los habitantes de
estos países queréis una prueba por
ejemplo en la segunda guerra mundial y
lanzar el australiana new zealand arm y
cork un ejército conjunto de australia
nueva zelanda combatió incluso en áfrica
y en europa apoyando directamente al
ejército británico
[Música]
pues bien desde el principio uno de los
argumentos clave de los euroescépticos
fue precisamente que era más importante
centrarse en la cabo web para crear una
gran unión de países anglosajones
especialmente con estos que hemos visto
fijaros lo que dice boris johnson uno de
los líderes del partido conservador que
más apoyo del brasil y que hoy es ni más
ni menos el ministro de exteriores del
reino unido- cuando londres se unió al
mercado común a la unión europea
traicionó su relación con países de la
commonwealth como australia y nueva
zelanda pues bien hoy es el sueño de
muchos británicos podría estar a punto
de cumplirse e incluso ya tiene un
nombre cantú
camps si os fijáis cantú que es una
palabra compuesta por las iniciales de
estos cuatro países canadá australia
nueva zelanda new zealand y reino unido-
y nadie más
pues bien lo cierto es que la unión
económica de estos países tiene mucho
sentido ojo unión económica y comercial
no política porque aquí los anglosajones
son muy celosos de su soberanía pero por
qué digo que tiene sentido pues porque
los estudios demuestran que cuando hay
lazos culturales las relaciones
económicas son más grandes por ejemplo
dos países que comparten idioma
comercian hasta un 40 por ciento más
entre sí y si además de compartir idioma
comparten también historia entonces
comercian atentos al dato un 188 por
ciento más que se dice proceso
[Música]
fijaros los países que forman el cáncer
que son todos muy ricos suponen
aproximadamente el siete por ciento de
la economía mundial pues bien a pesar de
ello eeuu que es muy similar y comparte
con ellos idioma cultura e historia
concentra en estos países el 25 por
ciento de todas sus inversiones en el
mundo pero qué importancia tendría
cáncer pues la verdad es que sus
dimensiones son importantes hablamos de
un grupo con 129 millones de habitantes
que unidos serían la tercera economía
del planeta y también el tercer mayor
presupuesto militar
vamos que este club anglosajón sería un
grupo bastante influyente y desde luego
reino unido sería su gran referente si
vale alguno diréis enrique la unión
europea es muchísimo más grande es
verdad pero es que aquí no acaba la
historia
[Música]
el acercamiento a eeuu de llevarse a
cabo este espacio de libre comercio y
libre movimiento de personas la relación
de campo con eeuu sería muy especial al
fin y al cabo kanczuk está integrado por
los mayores aliados del país del country
los perritos calientes y los cowboys de
hecho a día de hoy eeuu ya tiene en
vigor tratados de libre comercio con
canadá y australia y su actual
presidente
donald trump al que ya sabéis todo el
cariño que tenemos en este canal
y de la
se ha pronunciado a favor de firma muy
rápido otro tratado con reino unido
agradece el compromiso de trump sobre un
acuerdo comercial con londres y ojo con
las implicaciones que esto tiene si
londres consigue que el proyecto campus
salga adelante y además consigue firmar
el tratado de libre comercio con eeuu
cosas que a día de hoy parecen muy
factibles el mercado al que tendrían
acceso las empresas británicas sería el
doble de grande de lo que hoy es el
mercado común de la unión europea vamos
que de reino unido a medio plazo incluso
podría salir ganando
[Música]
y ojo porque como os venimos diciendo en
visual político hay que ver qué termina
ocurriendo con la negociación del break
sí pero aún hay más cansa tendría muchas
opciones de cuajar mejores relaciones y
mejores acuerdos con aquellos países con
los que comparten lazos históricos como
el resto de miembros de la commonwealth
por ejemplo singapur malasia la india
sudáfrica en total 52 países y no nos
olvidemos tampoco de otros como hong
kong o israel
[Música]
vamos que puede que sea un poco excesivo
hablar del regreso del imperio británico
pero lo cierto es que la formación de
este gran club anglosajón podría estar
en marcha de momento existe apoyo social
y político más que de sobra para
llevarlo a cabo
amigos las implicaciones de algo así
serían enormes y la verdad a muchos en
bruselas se les quedaría cara de tontos
puede que por eso teresa mail para
sorpresa de muchos haya decidido
negociar fuerte con la unión europea
por cierto si aún no lo has visto no te
pierdas este vídeo donde nuestro amigo
sebastián te cuenta qué puede pasar con
la city tras el éxito bueno tú qué
piensas crees que veremos la unión de
todos los pueblos anglosajones tendría
éxito el reino unido- con su nueva
política exterior tras el praxis
deberíamos los pueblos hispanos apostar
por una fórmula similar no dudes en
dejarnos tu opinión en los comentarios y
ya sabes si éste te ha resultado
interesante darle al botón de like y si
aún no lo has hecho ya no olvides
suscribirte al canal un saludo y hasta
la próxima
[Música]